so Maxine Waters caused a bit of
consternation when she encouraged her
supporters to harass Trump cabinet
officials and staff
I wasn't especially consternated myself
is consternated a word yeah it's it's
one of those words it sounds like it
isn't a word but I think it is word
I wasn't especially consternated myself
because I expect nothing but bile and
nonsense to spew from the mouth of one
Maxine Waters although this I admit was
several steps beyond the normal bile
that you expect from her and it was
truly dangerous and this story along
with or this rant of waters that along
with the thing that prompted it which of
course is Sarah Sanders getting kicked
out of a restaurant in Virginia seems to
have sparked renewed discussion about
the possibility that we could be headed
into a civil war in this country now I
don't personally think that Sarah
Sanders being interrupted in the midst
of her cheese plate is the kind of thing
that would normally spark a civil war it
would certainly be the weirdest civil
war of all time if that's what it was
fought over
but I do think that it's symptomatic it
is just one really faint in itself
insignificant symptom of something
and there have been many other symptoms
oh the rnc and I don't usually say this
about the rnc about really anything the
RNC does but the RNC released a truly
devastatingly effective ad yesterday
that kind of compiles some of the
dangerous rhetoric we've seen from the
left recently we roll that ad actually
we roll it no we can't roll it I don't
in fact I'm not talking to anyone
there's nobody over there I'm just just
my webcam so I can't roll and he adds
for you but after this you can go on
youtube and watch it yourself it is an
effective ed
and it all kind of shows that something
something not good
is is happening in America and were
headed to
well I won't say we're headed to a civil
war as I've argued before I don't see a
civil war on the horizon for this one
single reason our saving grace is that
we're we're far too lazy and apathetic
to actually fight a civil war because
that requires effort you know that
requires requires you to get off your
couch and stop watching Netflix and put
down the Twitter for a second and so I
just you can't fight an actual civil war
with means as what I'm saying so that's
why III don't I don't think we quite
have the Constitution the personal
Constitution the spine the motivation to
actually go out and fight us if a civil
war but we could very well be headed to
turmoil of some kind to anarchy honestly
we already live in a country of moral
Anarchy and I think we could see that
anarchy bleed out into the streets it
already has I think the situation we
could be headed to is it was was all we
already got kind of a preview of it a
few years ago with all those riots that
broke out in Ferguson and Baltimore and
other places I think we could see a lot
of that happening across the country all
at once
maybe that's what our civil war would
look like
it is in other words it's clear that
we're sitting on a powder keg
and in fact worse than that I would say
we're sitting on five powder kegs all at
once
and if they all blow at the same time
then then I don't know what happens but
it won't be good so let's go through
let's look at the powder kegs that we're
sort of cultural powder kegs just so we
understand the situation in our culture
the first one is is is one that I've
talked about many times we have nothing
in common with each other in this
country there is no unifying principle
no unifying idea or characteristic we
simply have nothing in common and that's
a big problem in any country it's
especially a problem in our country
because our country was founded upon an
idea our country was founded much more
like a religion than a country because
it was founded on a doctrine we have
founding doctrines we have a national
dogma most countries don't have that
they may have their own doctrines their
own ideas but those developed over time
while the country already existed for us
it was different it was like this is
what we believe and now we're going to
form a country around it
so as I've asked in the past what
happens when a large portion of the
country no longer believes in that idea
well you can't really have a country
anymore now if everybody were to to
abandon those founding ideas and then
coalesce around some other idea well
then you could have a country it
wouldn't be the United States of America
anymore it wouldn't be an American
country it wouldn't be a country that I
wanted to live in but it would be a
country in some sort of country but for
us we just have no country because we
have nothing in common we have no
there's no underlying thing tying us
together we don't even share a common
language anymore we don't share anything
the things that we share are the most
materialistic and superficial kinds of
things like we all you know it's it's
it's it's about you know it is we share
the same brands okay we all like Apple
and we drink Starbucks and we watch
Marvel movies that's what we have in
common but that is not enough to make a
country
that's enough to make a brand that's
enough to sustain sustain a company but
a country is not supposed to be a
company it's supposed to be a country
and it's and so it requires something
deeper to tie everybody together it's
not enough this is why all this talk
about people say to me all the time they
say well why are you being so divisive
what let's be unified let's talk about
what unites us okay great well then tell
me what the thing is that unites us and
I'll talk about it go ahead let me know
because I what is it you want me to talk
about the things that unite us okay what
anything
there's nothing
we don't have the so so so it sounds
really nice to say let's be united let's
let's all unify you have to unify around
something you can't just unify for the
sake of unifying
and that requires some kind of
commonality so here's the problem if I
were to open my door and invite a
radical leftist in which I would
certainly have no problem doing we could
sit down get a beer and talk but the
issue is that
the radical leftist and there's really
no distinction between a radical leftist
and a non radical there's billions no
such thing as a non radical leftist
anymore so the leftist you know they
live in a world
or this left this hypothetical leftist
who's coming in my house and sharing a
beer he lives in a world where there is
no God there is no objective morality
the institution of the family is
patriarchal and oppressive
marriage doesn't matter or doesn't
really exist
honestly babies aren't people
there is no bio there's no that the
biological differences between men and
women don't exist or don't matter there
is no real difference between men and
women the history of our country is
shameful and we need to apologize for it
America is fundamentally an evil country
the West is fundamentally evil okay and
in on and on and on that's the world he
lives in
where's the unity what am i I have
nothing in common with this guy that
does yes I can be polite to him I could
be nice I can be I can be decent towards
him I can even be civil
most of the time it's a little bit
difficult some but I can even be civil
but if you ask me to unite with them
well I just I literally can't do that
because there's nothing there there is a
great vast chasm that separates me from
him and there is simply no way to bridge
it there is no bridge that will connect
those two sides we live in two different
universes we have different ideas about
literally everything there is nothing
there is no there is nothing at all to
unify around
so it's just not helpful and this is the
problem there are people who you know
they want to be the good guys so they
want to talk about let's let's tell it
to stop with the divisiveness let's
unite okay shut up with that for a
second and tell me what were uniting
around and if you can't tell me that
then stop talking about unity and admit
that there can't be any
so that's the first problem the first
powder-keg second powder-keg is that
many of us were raised in unstable or
broken or emotionally chaotic families
and that links to the third powder-keg
which is that very many of us have had
no real moral formation to speak of
traditionally typically a person is
morally formed and that is it that's a
process that needs to happen it needs to
be an active process you can't just
throw somebody out there into the world
and say hey figure it out well you need
to do from with someone from a very
young age is morally formless to teach
them right from wrong and to how to live
as a decent person
so traditionally where do you look for
that well first you look to the family
well not first but together you look to
the family the domestic church and you
also look to the church
the Christchurch okay so you look to you
look to religion and you look to the
family to morally form people
well there's a big problem here because
a great many of us have fled from
religion we fled from the church and we
come from broken families so where are
we going for moral formation
who is helping us from a young age who
is helping to shape us into moral and
decent people
nobody we're just a lot of people just
been left to kind of figure it out for
themselves and they haven't figured it
out unfortunately
and understandably
without the church without religion
without a family then where do you look
you end up looking to TV you look to the
media with the Hollywood god forbid you
look to academia even worse than that
god forbid you look to the government
and politicians well you're not gonna
find it anywhere they're all you're
gonna find is moral corruption insanity
confusion manipulation you're not going
to find firm formation so those are two
and three
the fourth powder keg is that we have
been desensitized
and a big part of this without moral
formation that's makes us susceptible to
the desensitization and then on top of
that we sit around watching screens all
day we watch TV we we sit in front of
screens for like 10 hours a day without
exaggeration 10 hours a day watching TV
or on our phones on the internet and so
there's this kind of disconnect
especially on the Internet
there is this disconnect where you can
engage with other people but without
necessarily recognizing their humanity
and that's why people are so nasty and
disgusting to each other online and I
know it's really easy to say
well that's just the Internet you know
that's not the real world yeah people
are people are horrible to each other
online they say the worst kinds of
things if you look at a if you look at a
the comment section under a YouTube
video if you go on Twitter or Facebook
where or anywhere really on the Internet
you're gonna find people treating each
other just in the most atrocious ways
imaginable but that's not the real world
that's not how it is in the real world
what are you talking about those are
people saying those things what do you
mean it's not the real world
those aren't it's not a fantasy those
aren't those aren't imaginary characters
the person who's anonymously saying
disgusting things online that's a person
saying them
that is a person revealing what is
inside their own heart now the fact that
that person will then can then put down
the computer or put down the phone and
go out into the real world and maybe if
you encountered that person at the
supermarket they would nod nicely to you
and say hey how are you good morning and
walk by you that doesn't prove that
what's happening online isn't real and
the fact you could have a polite
exchange with that person in the real
world doesn't prove that they're
actually a decent person no if they act
like a monster online then they're a
monster
the fact that they're polite in the real
world just means honestly that they're
cowards and that they don't have the
guts to to be that way when they're
facing someone face to face
but how they act online when when
they're able to be anonymous
and when they have that protection of
the screen
and when they're able to remove as I
said the the kind of separate
a person from their humanity and engage
with a person as if they have no
humanity you know how a person acts in
that context really tells you everything
you need to know about them and what's
going on inside their soul
if you have ever gone on a YouTube video
and told someone to kill themselves well
you're just a horrible person I mean
deep inside you are just a horrible
terrible person and I don't care how
nice you are
at work to your coworkers
you're only nice because you're a wimp
and you would never say that to their
face but that's what's going on inside
your heart
you
and the internet breeds that kind of
thing because it desensitizes us it
numbs us and there's just this kind of
filter the separation
you
where we're able to engage with other
people and encounter things that are
really horrible yet it doesn't affect us
the same way that it would if we
encountered those things in the real
world and so again there's that it just
has the effect of numbing us and then
you add on top of that the media movies
TV video games everything else where we
just typically we look to the most
horrible that the darkest most violent
things for entertainment and then that
continues to numb us even more and then
we get to the fifth powder keg after
we've already you know we're already
living in a country that's not united we
have nothing in common many of us come
from unstable families many of us have
had no moral formation many of us are
desensitized in them and then you get to
now where now we're very vulnerable for
this fifth step this fifth powder-keg
which is the dishonesty and manipulation
of the media and politicians and
academia
and basically all of our leading
institutions the institutions that are
that have taken on the responsibility of
leading the culture and unfortunately
they are all infested with dishonest
manipulative people
and we most of us are very susceptible
and vulnerable to those dishonest and
manipulative people because of the last
four things that I mentioned
those are the powder cakes what happens
when they all blow up I don't know like
I said I don't know exactly
what can we do about it
I mean how can we avoid this explosion
how can we reclaim America how can we
come right up to the precipice of
disaster and then quickly swerve and go
the opposite direction
I don't know exactly but I do know one
thing I've been saying this for a long
time I know it's not what people want to
hear because what people want is a quick
kind of just snap your fingers switch on
a light sort of solution and I don't
have it I don't think that solution
exists what I do know is we've gotten to
this point as a culture over the course
of generations so what does that tell me
it tells me that if we're going to go
the other way
and we're going to solve these problems
and we're going to have a real country
again where we're actually where we are
meaningfully United around something
well it took us generations to get away
from that point it's going to take us
generations to get back to it
so you and I we're not going to see more
than likely what we're going to see is
we're going to see things get worse
we're not going to see the United
America I'm sorry we just won't
because you can't wander that far away
from it for so long and then all of a
sudden just you know what never mind and
then the entire culture says you know
what let's just change and do this
instead
that doesn't happen I'm sorry
it is a generational struggle
which is going to require selflessness
on our part
we're we're saying you know what we're
in for some rough times you and I
but we need to start thinking about the
future we need to start thinking about
our kids and our grandkids
how could we put them on a trajectory
where they don't have to suffer through
the same kinds of things
how can we put them on a trajectory
where maybe they can live in a real
country because we don't and we won't
so that's what we need to work on is
accept the fact
that we have kind of made our bed
culturally speaking and you and I we're
gonna have to lay in it and it's not
gonna be fun
but I think generally over the course of
generations maybe we can maybe there's
light you know there at the end of that
tunnel
and that's going to require while we
look at these five steps
we kind of have to do the opposite with
our own kids we've to get married form
families have kids and do the opposite
of all these things with them
number one we have to give them real
solid principles
and ideas
that can motivate them and also they can
unite with others around those ideas
number two we have to be a stable family
number three we have to morally form our
children
number four we have to avoid we have to
we have to do what we can to protect
them from the desensitization that
happens online and when you're obsessed
with screens and everything else and
then number five we do all that then
maybe they won't be as vulnerable to the
manipulation of politicians in the media
and academia and so
that's the solution
where there is hope but it's
further down on the horizon
and we have to be willing to do the work
to get there
you
all right
so it's not all doom and gloom I mean
unfortunately there's a lot of doom and
gloom before you get to the hope but you
know we just we have to be willing to to
suffer through it thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed